so I also tweeted and don't generally
like for wives now again there's
the atom 22 Exceptions there is the I
don't know uh I guess the Logan Paul
exceptions but this isn't before and the
problem is we keep looking at women that
are exceptionally hot that get away with
it so the average chick would never be
able to get away with the level of
promiscuity that Nina Agdal and Lena did
especially if it was public you know and
I again I I think because sometimes
girls will say oh but this chick you
know was able to pull that guy and she
was a and my answer is she's
hotter than yeah the top ten twenty
percent of women get exceptional
outcomes